this is a call the benefit of the doubt
review where you know you're kind of
like yeah it's awful but we'll give you
some credit on some things because we're
being really nice to you today hi i'm
ryan right and i'm gerry and I'm cat
welcome to reasons to see where we give
you reasons to see and not to see I
Frank inside so so let's hang out
hennessy number one Aaron Eckhart's body
alright so we just saw i frankenstein
and boy what a film yes there's Liam
what a delight this movie has six
percent on rotten tomatoes and honestly
it earns it earns that six-person but
there are a few reasons to see it just
like this reason aaron eckhart shirtless
hell yeah yeah yeah it was a great
moment you know when it happens you're
like okay okay cool yeah but i feel like
i didn't waste my money yeah it's a good
moment it's a really it's cheesy about
the film literally it builds that moment
up and then stops to go look how buffy
is where was it bolts they're new both
no bolts bolts following the makeup on
it was awful to actually i believe in
the book there are no bolts product of
zero dramatic yes dr. Frankenstein must
have done a very good job picking a
bunch of corpses that all looked very
similar yeah yeah I can to Mexico well
yeah it's like he just looks like one
guy but that moment yeah this has become
a thing in all of these movies where
it's like there is a mandatory it's a
trope now where it's like the troubled
hero but secretly he's really buff yeah
it's atomic it's like a thing for actors
now it's expected you know if you watch
like old school movies with action
heroes like 70s like Charlton Heston
they do you like they were like cut they
were like strong but nowadays like it's
expected then again you know there's
Arnold Schwarzenegger
yeah the Rambo luck to you know like you
know Sylvester Stallone really was
pretty buff I feel is that if there was
there was a time where actors would do
this get buff and it was like all over
the news now when it happens it's like
yeah you're supposed to good job yeah so
brooding the whole time yes reason to
see number two some of the visuals some
of the visuals are okay there are a
handful of really bad ass shots the
ending credits you know this cool like
pictures of the gargoyles those are
kinda yeah yeah the ending credits they
really what you gonna watch I'm happy
they use so many practical effects in
addition to all the CG and at least the
main body looked good oh you haven't
they turn back into stone that was any
effect but overall for me I thought most
of the visual effects were incredibly
cheesy yeah I thought they look like a
total like straight to DVD been going on
yeah it was pretty evident yeah yeah
it's better than the sci-fi channel but
it's sort of like you can tell which
scenes they spent money on and which
scenes that you've done crazy to see
number three some of the action some of
the action is good yeah actually you
know I thought like there's not that
much action in this felt but when there
is action it's good but there's also not
that much film like this movies like 78
minutes long and it feels like it's 45
minutes long yeah oh that's a hour and
40 minutes it's an hour flight yeah you
should I didn't feel like I'm looking
this up right yes I saw it on freaking
flixster clicksters what [ __ ] liar
Fandango says it's an hour and 33 ok I
was off by seven minutes still that's a
lot longer than I thought to you but
yeah the action in it though there's
some cool moments kind of Alex Sherlock
Holmes 300 thing even though sometimes
you're like why is Frankenstein a
martial artist yeah I don't remember his
nunchuck weapons I guess that was yeah I
like new they like the blade thing you
had at the end of that was cool yeah the
blades are kind of cool he's [ __ ] up
all those college kids you know what
this movie taught me Frankenstein he
doesn't like to use doors it's all about
jumping through windows with this guy
nobody can this movie likes to use any
traditional form of getting to work room
to the next it's just like go through a
wall through a window and through the
floor let's throw somebody and he pushes
one nor in this movie right he does put
one wall or open she does arcs free just
like Frankenstein all right I used to
deny vacated yeah when she was a kid
Frankenstein's a professional Archer
like Legolas I ever has probably but I
did appreciate that they at least took
the time to specify that he's not really
Frankenstein his Frankenstein's monster
yeah they definitely wrote that into it
where they're like oh you know
Frankenstein is his father so he's
taking on Frankenstein is his last name
and that's why it's i Frankenstein
instead of I Frankenstein's monster so
twice in fact just in case you didn't
catch it the first time in the movie
they address that you know I appreciated
the writer covering their bases there
and he does he does say it he does say i
Frankenstein at one point does pichler
moment variance yeah it's uh really gets
at that heart of yours and it's like oh
my god he is pretty well up it's true
yeah reasons not to see the acting whoo
I have never seen such a bad movie where
every actor is unbelievably committed
yet yeah it's like horrible acting at
the same time they all are in the same
movie but kind of in different movies
you're really committed and I don't
think this is a bad performance but then
like Jai Courtney comes on screen and
now I'm like you're really committed I
don't think this is a good performance
still nah he's just doing his bill nighy
thing yeah bill nighy plays a bad guy
and would have seen that coming I
thought that that doctor was pretty good
she's cute she's cute yeah she's really
sure you look Kate Winslet just a little
bit nobody Kate Winslet yeah I don't see
a tiny bit reasons up to see number two
Aaron Eckhart if there's one performance
of serious commitment it's aaron [ __ ]
a garden style I think he forgot that he
was in the dark night because he clearly
absorbed Christian Bale when he thought
of this performance all right the
guttural yeah I'm Frankenstein god it
was such bad acting I could not believe
what I was watching reason at the scene
3 the righty you can't really blame than
one hundred percent the lines okay see I
think anyone would have a challenge
making most of those oh yeah the writing
was so horrible I'm not a human okok on
some honesty I walked in a little late
to this film so I have to have Jerry
catch me up I remember like he was
trying to catch me up and I'm like a
still don't know what's going on and
then at one point aaron eckhart just
decides to recap the first 20 minutes
and I'm like perfect I've caught up
among the writers really careful about
that he even has the bad guy like I'm a
demon Prince yeah everything is so
expositional you know bad guys are the
stupidest in this movie what cuz when
bad guys have the opportunity to kill
the main hero they never do it they love
to get this whole speech about you know
what's really going on to explain the
block for you and then you know the bad
guy gets killed and it's like God idiot
you just give you kill him a second ago
you wouldn't be dead now you know very
James Bond very James Bond is there a
number of scenes constantly they capture
him and the book and then they're like
don't don't go after him they should
have called this in her they should have
called this movie The Journal cuz it is
all about like this one journal old
notebook ya know yeah ah i jizz it
pretty and funny huh huh that's cool
right everything felt like it was very
quick like whereas something would take
two or three scenes to unfold in most
movies like this they just crammed
everything into one scene so all the
major developments feel like oh all
right there's the book oh hey oh okay he
got it back Oh whoopsie lost i don't
know he's got it back again i won't ruin
them the major plot development but
there is one very crucial plot
development that literally just comes
out as like oh i guess we were wrong i
think it are you talking about yeah i'll
ruin it because guess what it's a piece
of [ __ ] movie don't really care this is
a spoiler but it's most obvious spoiler
in the film at one point like 20 minutes
in you know they tell Frankenstein you
don't have a soul oh no he's been
dealing like this this is the whole
movie and yes I'm dealing but I don't
have a soul lover my
I'm a monster abomination of course
you're gonna be like maybe he's gonna
have a soul by the end of it yeah and
they try to put like a demon soul in him
cuz he doesn't have a soul and then he's
like without with no pomp or
circumstance it's just like oh well
guess that didn't work yeah oh he's got
a soul up your old it wasn't an art to
him having a soul it was just like this
is a fact yeah looks like we have a
shame he doesn't grow it oh yeah joke's
on you kid I actually had all his old
that reason at the sea number four
they're directing the directing of this
film this guy I think took this movie
way too seriously I thought he should
have had a lot more fun with the tone
because it was weird because it's like
it's over the top it's cheesy as hell
it's just horrible yet it's kind of a
boring film at the same time yeah which
is surprising you it should be so easy
to make a film about Frankenstein
especially if you're throwing in like
extra mythologies yeah about a meeting I
should be exciting his at the very least
yeah usually the movies this bad it's
entertaining it's just such a boring
film I mean I was always at least I
never got like oh pick it up I was
always mildly entertained but it is kind
of I do get what you're saying I close
my eyes for a little bit and I was still
able to keep up with everything that's
going on this movie just takes itself so
it's so self-important yeah it's like
dude you got a Frankenstein minute okay
like the end make invisible war going on
between the demons and the gargoyles
give the character some kind of range of
emotions because Frankenstein is always
brooding Bill Nye is always sniveling
Jai Courtney is always angry angsty you
know the queen is always airy and regal
and it's like the doctors there to ask
questions the scientist yeah yeah it's
like everyone does one thing all the
time it's like very two tone something
do something different and I mean
there's all right it was it was fairly
watchable like it was a serviceable film
I thought but my disagree yeah and held
my attention walk out being like angry
or like [ __ ] dis movie but I was like a
pretty bad I walked out slay me
or I was [ __ ] you freaking there's no
bad sound quality just don't like the
guy but nice body oh yeah Frankenstein's
good good work Aaron do you really got
about this is the most committed I've
seen you soon I'm impressed and if
there's any movie you want to do method
acting on I totally get what you did it
for this I love didn't thank you for
smoking and I loved you in the dark
night I you're good the good and it did
kind of feel just a little bit like they
were just trying to like put in a few
scars as possible so that you could just
show how attractive you looked it was a
twilight esque choice yeah it was like
beastly where it's like I'm a monster
which means I have really cool scar yeah
I go to Monster High Ryan's consensus a
contender for the worst movie of the
year already is the reason not to see i
frankenstein a contender for the worst
movie of the year already is the reason
not to see i frankenstein ya january
exists for a reason it is to get all the
piece of [ __ ] movies out of the way
Jerry's consensus if you're bored at
home on a Saturday and you need
something to watch that's the reason OC
i frankenstein if you're bored at home
on a Saturday you need something to
watch that's the reason to see i
frankenstein like it's really bad but
i'm not upset about like it like I would
put it on in the background again and it
would probably be fine so yeah cats
consensus reasons to see i frankenstein
aaron eckhart shirtless reason to see i
frankenstein aaron eckhart shirtless
yeah i mean he was pretty cute he got
pretty buff if nothing else go for the
eye candy and you know he's shirtless
it's pretty obvious he's flexing oh yeah
yep cuz he stands he's like standing yes
he's like trying to look like he's
covering himself but he's also got his
arm he's got our been still look he's
like totally flexing his pecs but still
if i look like that i would probably do
the same time alright guys thanks for
checking out our awesome review for i
Frankenstein why don't you go ahead
scroll that comment box below and tell
us which actor would you like to see get
buff yeah that once you're done with
that once you come over here and click
this boot on so you can see more
episodes the reasons to see because
there's more than one of them and last
but
at least if you want to get updated
every time one of our views is out
subscribe yeah you got the scribe down
we didn't say the sub describer word
yeah describe his or scribes or you said
such good I heard you just sing scribe
maybe you said sub really low and scrubs
scrubs are really committed more to it
yeah one person he's probably introduce
you to cat uh we haven't done didn't
told you anything about her uh yeah
she's um she's multi-talented ready
ready to wrap this [ __ ] off actress
writer director cinematographer editor
artist painter Archer yeah what else do
you do um I do you again yoga ever no
I'm say where she does you gotta be [ __ ]
though oh yeah if I stop it yeah she is
yoga runs very talented inky very
talented running it's definitely a
talent yeah I was like you gotta come on
the show guess how we met her yes every
met her craigslist.com five that's right
that ad worked we need a girl to come to
our apartment so we can [ __ ] her and I
really yeah it was granny she responded
right away me raising luckily we're not
creepy but but why did you respond to
that it's a medical youtube more do I
like the show we're two dudes come new
apartment come to our apartment in
filmer homeless I'm sorry you know what
I realize why did you let a creepy girl
come to your apartment that's the real
question well usually the creepers are
the ones answer you're a pretty creepy
girl so you know will endure the
creepiness awesome yeah you know you
know it is because
you